ان نعرف منك عموما اخر ما تقوله اسرائيل
بخصوص حربها في غزه ونبدا بهذا العاجل عن
ان تقديرات الجيش تشير الى احتمال ان
تستغرق المعارك في خان يونس اشهر هل لديك
تفاصيل هذا ما نقلته اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن مصادر عسكريه عليا في الجيش
تقول بان حركه حماس وكتائب القسام استدعت
كوادرها في ارجاء قطاع غزه ل استنفرتم
وتحق بحجم في منطقه خان يونس هذه الجبهه
التي تعتبرها بانها المعقل الاساسي لكتائب
القسام وقيادتها وبناء على ذلك وضرا
القتال الجاري في خان يونس ومحيطها فانها
تتوقع بان الحرب ستستغرق اشهرا حتى يتم
حسمها في خانيونس التي تقول انها المعقل
الاساسي هذه المعارك الضاريه التي تجري
هناك والتي خلفت مزيد زيدا من القتلى في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي والكثير من الضحايا
في صفوف المواطنين الفلسطينيين والمقاومين
واضح بانها تعتبرها اسرائيل احد اهم وربما
الاهم بين ميادين القتال والمحاور في قطاع
غزه اذا ما اضيفت اليها ضاحيه الشجاعيه
التي تقوم قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بتدميرها بشكل منهجي وقد منيت فيها بخسائر
عاليه بالارواح واعترفت بانها تجد فيها
كمائن وخدع تمارسها كتائب القسام وقتال
ضار من قبل مقاتليها بالاضافه الى مخيم
جباليا لذلك جاءت هذه التقديرات على اساس
بخصوص خان يونس على اساس ان خان يونس
ومخيمها منها ينحدر يحيى السنوار وكذلك
محمد ضيف قائدا القسام وقائدا هذه
المقاومه في قطاع غزه المقاومه الضاريه
ومن المعارك الدائره وفق التقديرات
الاسرائيليه فان قياده القسام ما زالت
تمسك بزمام المبادره في المعارك وتديرها
بشكل كامل وليس مثل ما كانت تردد بعض
المصادر الاسرائيليه منذ اسبوعين بان هناك
بدايات انكسار في اوساط او في صفوف كتائب
القسام وحركه حماس هذه التقديرات تشير الى
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي باد يدرك انه امام
معركه لن تنتهي بثلاثه اسابيع مثل ما كان
يطالب جيك سلفان الاسرائيليين في مباحثاته
معهم الاخيره وانما ستمتد لاشهر الان
يتحدثون نحن في اليوم الاني من هذه الحرب
وا واضح بانهم عندما يتحدثون عن اشهر معنى
ذلك انه حتى لو توقف الاجتياح او القتال
فان اسرائيل تنوي مواصله حربها على هيئه
غارات عسكريه وتولا او عمليات غزو عسكريه
في عمق قطاع غزه